[Música]
la extrema derecha ganó en chile y se
quedó con la mayoría de los escaños del
recién elegido consejo constitucional de
esta manera el partido republicano pasó
de rechazar el cambio de la Carta Magna
a tener el peso preponderante para
terminar de escribir el segundo borrador
de la constitución política del país con
los comicios del Siete de mayo se queda
con 23 de los 51 escaños totales del
organismo esto es dos puestos más de los
necesarios para imponer un poder de veto
y cuatro menos para ser mayoría sin
embargo la derecha tradicional podría
ayudarle Pues el colectivo chile seguro
obtuvo once escaños mientras que los
partidos de izquierda que respaldan al
presidente Gabriel borich y que se
aliaron en el grupo unidad para Chile
tendrán 16 puestos de esta manera el
país austral continúa su segundo intento
para redactar una nueva constitución que
reemplace a la que se describió en los
tiempos de la dictadura de Augusto
pinochet luego de que la primera versión
se hundiera en el de 2022 Pero cómo
pasaron los chilenos de una de las
constituciones más progresistas del
mundo en al menos en su borrador al
consejo Constituyente dominado por la
ultraderecha y la derecha habrá o no
cambios estructurales respecto a la
actual Carta Magna eso es lo que
debatiremos hoy en el debate yo soy
María Clara calle y a partir de hoy los
acompañaré en este programa para
analizar nuestro tema del día tenemos a
dos invitados que se conectan desde la
ciudad de Santiago ellos son Felipe
munizaga director de las fundaciones
libertarias Robert nocic y Hayek labs y
Daniel Olivares ex candidato Al consejo
constitucional por convergencia social
uno de los partidos que respalda a boric
y que hace parte de la unidad para Chile
antes de comenzar le recuerdo a ustedes
nuestros televidentes que también hacen
parte de este debate pueden dejar todos
sus comentarios y preguntas en las redes
sociales nos encuentran en Twitter
Facebook e Instagram como arroba
franz24-raya al piso e s pueden comentar
con la etiqueta numeral el debate f24 y
a mí me encuentran en Twitter como
arroba María claguirre no olviden que
todos los contenidos de nuestro programa
también están disponibles en Apple
podcast Spotify deezer y TuneIn
Ahora sí comenzamos en nuestro debate Y
le doy la bienvenida a Felipe y a Daniel
Gracias por acompañarnos y quiero
proponerle a Felipe que comience
respondiendo la pregunta con la que
comenzamos el debate Cómo se pasa de un
borrador que podría llegar a ser la
Constitución más progresista al menos de
la región a un consejo constitucional
dominado por la derecha
Muy buenas tardes María Clara a todas
las personas que nos escuchan Daniel
también Buenas tardes
bueno es bastante difícil de entender y
bastante difícil de explicar
la yo creo que esto es un proceso que
aún no no ha concluido hay libros que se
están escribiendo y se han escrito al
respecto pero yo puedo adelantar
fundamentalmente dos cosas La primera es
que esta Constitución propuesta por la
anterior convención constitucional donde
el extrema izquierda tenía absoluta
mayoría de donde hicieron lo que
quisieron todo ese proceso era una
constitución absolutamente alejada y
ajena de lo que ha sido históricamente
la tradición política chilena Y a eso le
tenemos que sumar otra situación y más
que una situación un conjunto de
situaciones que eran muy graves por
ejemplo había gente que votaba desde la
ducha
y estoy viéndolo de una manera bastante
Clara hay gente por ejemplo que iba
de Pikachu hay gente que se ponía a
cantar dentro de la de la convención y
la verdad que nosotros los chilenos no
no estamos acostumbrados a ese tipo de
situaciones y esto yo creo que a la a la
izquierda y a la extrema izquierda le le
afectó de una manera muy grande porque
esto que pasó el domingo Es la segunda
gran derrota de la izquierda que ha
intentado por todos los medios de
exculparse y de culpar digamos a
situaciones incluso externas pero la
verdad es que el chileno promedio el
chileno medio la clase media es bastante
intuitiva y quiere vivir en paz quiere
vivir tranquilo ya rechazado ya dos
veces esta propuesta que le ha hecho la
convención constitucional la convención
Constituyente hoy día se pasó a un
proceso completamente diferente yo
difiero yo no soy del partido
republicano pero difiero que el partido
republicano encarne la extrema derecha
Aunque Sí hay extrema derecha
funcionando en Chile como funcionan en
muchos países
y creo que es un proceso que que para mí
es una última es la última oportunidad
para que la clase política pueda brindar
soluciones a las personas que están
demandandolo hace muchos años y la gente
además ha entendido que gran parte de
los problemas no son constitucionales
sino que son institucionales y es la
clase política en la que no ha sabido
darle solución a este a este proceso
antes de continuar solo una aclaración Y
es que nos referimos al partido
republicano como extrema derecha ya que
el panorama político de chile es
bastante abierto y por la derecha
tradicional se entiende el colectivo que
fue como chile seguro que son
concretamente en la unión demócrata la
renovación social y el eópolis Entonces
estos partidos los entendemos como
derecha y más hacia el extremo político
está el partido del ex candidato José
Antonio kast Le quiero preguntar y es
por qué cre e usted estas A qué se deben
estas dos derrotas a la izquierda tanto
ahora en las elecciones del Consejo
constitucional como en el referendo de
septiembre del año pasado en el que se
hundió y la mayoría de los chilenos
decidió hundir el primer borrador de la
constitución
bueno fundamentalmente porque hay una
disociación inmensa entre las élites y
sobre todo especialmente la la elip de
izquierda ha sido la que ha manejado los
últimos 15 o 20 años el país y la ley de
extrema izquierda
respecto de los problemas de las
personas Cuando a uno le preguntaban
había muchas encuestas a octubre del año
2019 en qué lugar estaba el cambio
constitucional dentro de las
preferencias de las personas el el tema
constitucional de un Rango de uno a
veinte o veinticinco temas estaba
siempre en los últimos lugares y en
algún minuto la la izquierda fue muy
hábil de convencer a una gran parte del
país que el país que teníamos era malo
que lo que habíamos hecho era era
horrible que todo estaba mal que había
que refundar el país de nuevo y la
verdad es que claro muchísima gente de
buena fe conció en eso Yo no niego que
haya situaciones que que hay que
resolver lo único que haya aún pobreza
no lo niego hay hay muchas situaciones
que que hay que que hay que arreglar y
que la clase política no la ha arreglado
no la solucionó pero las personas en
Chile quieren vivir en paz fíjese que
hoy día el en nuestro país nosotros
tenemos el mayor alza de asesinatos en
los últimos diez años cosa que no no
habíamos no estábamos acostumbrados
tenemos la mayor alza de violaciones que
eso tampoco estamos acostumbrados a
tener ese esa alza de violencia yo no
culpo completamente al gobierno del
frente amplio Aunque ellos son grandes
responsables de la violencia en Chile
Porque muchos de los personeros del
frente amplio tenían la siguiente frase
ellos decían nosotros comprendemos pero
no justificamos la violencia pero ese
esa comprensión muchas veces daba Paulo
a que no existiera una condena absoluta
y drástica respecto de los actos de
violencia que comenzaron a sucederse en
los meses previos a octubre de 2019 y
también a los meses posteriores al año
2019 entonces la gente las personas
están cansadas de proceso constitucional
están cansadas de la violencia la
araucanía es una zona que lleva varios
años Piñera tampoco lo solucionó con
situaciones de violencia con guerrilla Y
la verdad es que esta esta situación no
da para más y las personas hoy día le
están dando para mí entender la última
oportunidad de la clase política para
dar una solución a algunas cuestiones
constitucionales yo creo que en general
constitucionalmente chile no tiene
grandes problemas constitucionales Pero
sí hay un tema por lo menos de una parte
importante del electorado que del
legitima en la Constitución de 1980 y
eso puede ser complejo de resolver pero
las personas hoy día están en una
posición donde quieren Paz quieren
tranquilidad y quieren salir de la
situación es que la la política o los
políticos han
conducido al país sí estamos teniendo
unos problemas de conexión con nuestro
segundo invitado Daniel Olivares y
mientras lo resolvemos quiero continuar
con usted Felipe usted dice que la
mayoría de los chilenos quiere seguir en
paz y esto y que quiere la seguridad
esto refuerza un poco la idea que ha
defendido el partido republicano y es
que recordemos muy rápidamente el
proceso en chile y es que se elige en
2020 la mayoría de las personas votan un
plebiscito para cambiar la Constitución
y eligen al entonces a la entonces
convención Constituyente que era un
órgano de 155 representantes elegidos
popularmente y ellos redactaron el
primer borrador que como usted lo dice
proponía por ejemplo un estado
plurinacional donde se permitían y se
reconocían los diferentes pueblos
indígenas de chile entre otras medidas
que vamos a ir discutiendo sin embargo
esta primera versión de la Carta Magna
fue rechazada en septiembre de 2022 y
todo esto provocó una serie de cambios y
un segundo proceso para otra vez
intentar escribir la Constitución así en
diciembre del año pasado se a lo que se
conoció como el acuerdo de chile que
creó tres instituciones ellas son por un
lado la convención constitucional que se
eligió el 7 de mayo por otra parte la
comisión de expertos que está trabajando
desde el 6 de marzo hasta el 6 de junio
y que le pasará el anteproyecto de
Constitución a la convención
constitucional para que esta convención
de 51 miembros termine de discutir lo
que tendrá esta carta magna y finalmente
el comité técnico de admisibilidad que
son también conocidos Como los árbitros
mirarán si esto está de acuerdo o no sin
embargo este acuerdo para Chile este
acuerdo por chile que se pactó en
diciembre del 2022 y que fue con el que
se revivió el proceso Constituyente en
Chile después del rechazo del plebiscito
del 2022 el partido republicano no apoyó
este acuerdo y dijo que no lo apoyaba
porque para él la prioridad era la
seguridad no los cambios
constitucionales y también el partido
republicano no ha cortado del todo sus
vínculos con Augusto pinochet y la
dictadura de Augusto pinochet en este
sentido si la prioridad es la seguridad
como usted lo está diciendo Entonces por
qué continuar en el proceso
Constituyente
Bueno eso es una muy buena pregunta el
lo que desde fuera uno puede analizar es
que efectivamente el partido republicano
siendo un crítico del del proceso y
muchísima gente también te critica el
proceso porque el primer acuerdo que fue
el acuerdo de 2019 de noviembre del 2019
señalaba que si si ganaba la opción
rechazo
regía la Constitución la actual
Constitución de 1980 pero
desgraciadamente la clase política
desconoció de ese acuerdo porque
efectivamente eso fue así Y decidieron y
cuando hablo de la clase política me
refiero a los partidos de la derecha
tradicional renovación nacional la udi
desconocieron ese acuerdo y pactaron con
el gobierno realizar este plebiscito o
sea esta nueva este nuevo proceso
Constituyente sin un plebiscito de
entrada lo que a muchos a muchísima
gente le le molestó este proceso de
hecho yo no no es un estudio acabado del
tema de los nulos Pero me imagino que
mucho voto que tiene que ver con el
rechazo a este nuevo proceso
Constituyente porque la gente ya está
completamente cansada de estar en en una
situación de discusión constitucional lo
que ustedes es verdad el partido
republicano se abstuvo de de participar
se restó de esta mesa se restó de este
acuerdo pero ellos evaluaron por lo que
por lo que públicamente señalaron que no
había que quedarse fuera del proceso
porque eventualmente también podía pasar
que la izquierda tuviera nuevamente
control de la de la asamblea por lo
tanto ellos quisieron Y decidieron estar
nuevamente en el en el proceso bueno Y
ellos son un partido que de alguna
manera
ha expresado también una una
característica que otros grupos
políticos no no han tenido ellos han
mantenido un discurso parejo a lo largo
de muchísimos años fíjense que hay un
dato que que es muy importante que uno
conozca el el en la segunda vuelta del
año dos José Antonio kast logró
digamos un total de voto de tres
millones seiscientos cincuenta mil
ochenta y ocho votos y hoy día la
coalición que llevó a la ex a la a la
centro derecha más el partido
republicano lograron cinco millones
quinientos veintiocho mil votos o sea
lograron un millón ochocientos setenta y
siete mil novecientos votos más que lo
que obtuvo primero José Antonio kast y
al contrario la lista de de la centro
izquierda más la izquierda el frente
amplio obtuvo ochocientos cuarenta y
seis mil votos menos de los que obtuvo
Gabriel boric entonces uno podría
claramente señalar que acá hay un
castigo muy fuerte al gobierno hay un
castigo también Además del gobierno
aparte de la clase política a la centro
derecha básicamente porque ha habido un
cambio un discurso y las personas no
estaban en el tema constitucional y sí
estaban en la situación de seguridad sí
retomó un montón entonces un poco las
ideas que usted ha planteado la votación
del Consejo constitucional es un castigo
para el gobierno izquierdista de Gabriel
borich para la centro derecha y le más
poder al partido republicano a la
extrema derecha y también según usted
está reconociendo el cansancio de la
ciudadanía en general en Chile con el
proceso Constituyente ya tenemos de
nuevo a Daniel Olivares le doy la
bienvenida Gracias por estar con
nosotros usted está de acuerdo con lo
que plantea Felipe y si considero o no
paradójico que el partido republicano
que en un momento quiso quedarse casi al
margen del proceso Constituyente hoy por
hoy sea el que más escaños tendrá en el
consejo que terminará de redactar la
constitución
Hola muy buenas tardes un gran saludo
Disculpen los problemas de de
conectividad saludar a Felipe también y
muy de acuerdo con lo que estás
consultando claramente es una paradoja
enorme lo que vivimos el día domingo si
pensamos hace tres años el país tenía
una posición completamente distinta
estábamos a favor de un proceso
constitucional estábamos a favor de que
fuera un órgano electo 100% por la
ciudadanía que redactara una nueva carta
fundamental
era Era una situación muy
paradójicamente distinta a la que
pudimos ver este día domingo cuando son
precisamente las personas en este caso
el partido republicano que se opone a un
cambio constitucional que se opone a la
necesidad de discutir una nueva
constitución que se opone a cambios
fundamentales que están por ejemplo
plasmados hoy día en el nuevo proceso
constitucional que le hayan obtenido la
mayoría en en el nuevo consejo
constitucional Así que Efectivamente es
una paradoja y creo que junto con las
causas que ya se estaban mencionando
respecto
lo eventuales resultados que tuvimos el
día domingo y la interpretación a las
que nos llevan creo que hay mucho más
que analizar yo sumaría de que no solo
hay un voto de castigo a al gobierno que
es efectivo y que por nuestra parte
tenemos que hacer una profunda
autocrítica sino que también en nuestra
opinión aquí se sigue profundizando la
crisis de deslegitimidad de la clase
política Aquí también se sigue
profundizando la crisis de la
legitimidad de las dos coaliciones más
importantes que durante mucho tiempo
existieron en nuestro país por ejemplo y
por lo tanto es un escenario bien
complejo para la para la política actual
de nuestro país y aquí le quiero
preguntar algo y es teniendo en cuenta
que 34 de los 51 miembros del Consejo
constitucional serán de derecha y de
extrema derecha que tantos cambios puede
haber realmente frente a la Carta Magna
actual que como ya lo decía Felipe está
desde 1980 desde la dictadura de
pinochet
bueno nosotros precisamente hemos
planteado la tesis de que a 50 años de
la conmemoración del golpe de estado
Precisamente lo que necesita nuestro
país es dar una constitución nacida en
democracia y ese ha sido nuestra nuestra
tesis y la defensa que hemos hecho a un
proceso constitucional en estos tiempos
y y vuelvo a indicarlo a propósito de
conmemorar 50 años de golpe de estado
precisamente quienes resultaron electos
y obtuvieron la mayoría no han dejado
completamente acorralado a las fuerzas
oficialistas y a Los partidarios del
gobierno Quienes no logramos obtener los
resultados de este domingo ni siquiera
los dos los dos quintos que nos
permitiría haber obtenido el poder de
veto frente a una mayoría ya consolidada
de la derecha y la extrema derecha en el
resultado electoral de hecho muy por el
contrario en la lista oficialista en la
lista unidad para Chile nosotros
esperábamos sacar un resultado que nos
permitiera tener ese poder de veto para
precisamente poder plantearle a a la
derecha y a la extrema derecha la
necesidad de generar grandes acuerdos y
generar acuerdos transversales para
fijar un nuevo texto constitucional sin
embargo y volvemos a la paradoja ha sido
la extrema derecha y el partido
republicano quienes solo con sus
consejeros y consejeras electos han
obtenido ese poder de Beto y hoy día
podemos ver el ha circulado en en estos
días van Solo dos días desde que
transcurrieron del resultado de la
elección y ya estamos viendo por ejemplo
parlamentarios del partido republicano
que ya están haciendo un desconocimiento
del respaldo algunas de las dos ideas
fundamentales que vienen a fijar el
rayado cancha de este proceso
constitucional por ejemplo planteando
que no van a defender las ideas y no van
a defender en el proceso constitucional
el estado social y democrático derecho
es una de las bases fundamentales de
este proceso
usted menciona el estado social de
derecho es en estos momentos una de las
grandes pugnas frente a la Constitución
porque plantea el futuro que quiere
chile para la formación de su estado de
Nuevo teniendo en cuenta que vienen de
unas instituciones basadas y creadas en
tiempos de la dictadura Le quiero
preguntar a Felipe por dos cosas uno es
posible ver una transformación hacia el
estado social de derecho o en términos
de esta visión del estado que se puede
esperar de la Constitución y dos A qué
se puede deber esta derrota como lo
mencionaba Daniel que los oficialistas
ni siquiera lograron los 21 escaños que
necesitaban para el poder de Beto sino
Yo creo que la el frente amplio y los
grupos de extrema izquierda que apoyan
el frente amplio tienen un un grave
problema de conexión con la realidad y Y
eso no lo digo yo lo dice lo dice la
gente que se expresó el domingo que ha
rechazado lo que ellos han propuesto
desde el momento en que el primer
borrador constitucional se conoció la
tradición constitucional chilena es una
tradición que recoge el republicanismo
es una tradición que recoge la
democracia es una es una tradición que
recoge lo mejor que ha construido el
país a lo largo de cientos de a lo largo
de las décadas Entonces qué es lo que
sucede cuando uno lee o leyó el borrador
constitucional empieza a encontrar cosas
que son muy similares por ejemplo a
procesos que hay en Venezuela o que hubo
en Venezuela a procesos
en Bolivia y eso es completamente
diferente
respecto de lo que ha sido la tradición
chilena hoy día las discusiones que
existen al interior de la comisión de
tienen que ver con cosas como la que
usted acaba de decir que precisamente
chile tiene que tener el el nombre de un
estado social y democrático de derecho a
qué nos llevaría por ejemplo a tener el
nombre del estado social en el caso por
ejemplo tener una coalición de izquierda
hay que recordar que la convención
Constituyente del año pasado eh se
presentó cerca de 60.000 peticiones para
mantener la posibilidad que los
ahorrantes de las afp de las de las
aseguradoras del fondo de pensiones
fueron los dueños de sus fondos jamás se
permitió que esa esas peticiones esa
solicitud se discutiese siquiera dentro
de la convención Constituyente entonces
hay motivos de sobra para pensar que la
izquierda una vez que va a llegar el
poder va a desconocer el derecho de
propiedad de las personas Va a
desconocer las libertades ya la
personera de gobierno la ministra la
vocera del gobierno ha estado señalando
que quieren ellos enviar una que regule
entre comillas la fake news yo no tengo
problema con que con que alguien pueda
estar en contra porque por supuesto que
la la las noticias falsas Son son
complejas pero cuando los los gobiernos
empiezan a mandar leyes para regular la
libertad de prensa la libertad de
palabra ya estamos empezando de nuevo
con procesos que han sido históricamente
fracasados de países vecinos Entonces
eso la gente está reaccionando
republicanismo entonces como la
tradición política en Chile es lo que
usted defiende para decir la carta
constitucional nueva deberá tener esto
en vez de abrirlo a un estado social de
derecho y evitar un riesgo como usted lo
llama de que se desconozca el derecho a
la propiedad privada usted qué piensa de
esto Daniel
Bueno yo creo que y le pido a Felipe que
terminemos con la poca honestidad
intelectual lo que él está señalando es
un falso mito que ha sido derribado en
innumerable ocasiones con una serie de
de consideraciones que ha tomado el
gobierno que han tomado los liderazgos
de los parlamentarios también del del
frente amplio de la dignidad yo diría
que también del partido comunista el
partido socialista para despejar
completamente este mito que se ha
levantado como si la izquierda chilena
quisiera terminar con la propiedad
privada Yo le vuelvo a recordar a Felipe
y también vuelvo a recordar a quienes
nos nos pueden ver de que el gobierno
precisamente presentó por ejemplo una
propuesta de litio que tienen
consideración también el sector privado
y una estrategia donde tiene que
forjarse una alianza entre el sector
público entre el sector privado Entonces
yo De verdad espero que podamos de una
vez por todo iniciar el debate por el
bien de este país con todas las la
honestidad intelectual que permita
enfrentarla Con sinceridad y esa
sinceridad significa despejar
precisamente
los mitos como decir que la izquierda
chilena quiere terminar con la propiedad
privada que eso no es cierto que es
terminar con que precisamente
quisiéramos estatizarlo todo porque eso
no es cierto es terminar con el tercer
mito de que la izquierda chilena quiere
apropiarse de los fondos de pensiones de
los trabajadores eso no es cierto es un
mito y por lo tanto cuando podamos
superar eso vamos precisamente a dar los
debates con la sinceridad que nos
permita reconocernos en la diferencia y
encontrar los puntos en común que nos
permitan forjar precisamente una
constitución para el futuro lo que yo
estaba señalando y lo vuelvo a plantear
Discúlpame era de que precisamente
cuando vemos un parlamentario
republicano que está desconociendo las
doce bases fundamentales este proceso
constitucional eso precisamente atenta
con lo mismo que está señalando Felipe
con el republicanismo que significa
respetar el estado de derecho Qué
significa respetar las reglas del juego
y es precisamente lo que hacemos
nosotros al interior de nuestra propia
coalición Cuando alguien precisamente
muy descoordinadamente del espíritu que
nosotros tenemos precisamente desconoce
algún aspecto institucional que es
relevante hoy día está muy claro Cuáles
son los dos aspectos de este proceso
constitucional y en el marco de ese de
esas doce bases fundamentales se
estableció un acuerdo transversal para
fijar el estado social y democrático
derecho y es de esperar entonces que los
republicanos el partido republicano en
su conjunto con sus consejero y
consejeras además con su parlamentario
en el congreso respeten Esas reglas del
juego Como así también claramente el
mismo llamado que tenemos que hacer a
toda la fuerza de coaliciones políticas
del país porque claramente para que el
resultado este proceso termine en buena
en buena Elite tenemos que todo no
titubear a la hora de respetar
Precisamente lo que está fijado para
este proceso Daniel le quiero hacer una
pregunta muy breve antes de darle la
contrapregunta a Felipe y Daniela Le
quiero preguntar no fue precisamente en
contra o mejor por esos mitos que la
mayoría de los chilenos votó a favor de
otros partidos distintos a los oficiales
bueno Es probable que un poco de esos
factores haya incidido en en
precisamente perder una adhesión
electoral hacia nuestros partidos hacia
nuestra coalición de gobierno y hacia
nuestros sectores Pero también es cierto
de que ha incidido el trabajo
precisamente que se ha estado haciendo a
través de la generación de Face news a
través de insistir con esto con estos
mitos precisamente donde donde acusan a
la izquierda de ideas que no son
representadas por la izquierda hoy día
precisamente hemos hecho una autocrítica
profunda incluso haciéndonos cargo de
elementos que no eran de nuestra
responsabilidad en el proceso
constitucional anterior tenemos salido a
la calle y hemos sido candidato Al
consejo constitucional también nos hemos
hecho cargo de cada responsabilidad que
nos toca por ser partidarios del
gobierno y por lo tanto la autocrítica
la estamos haciendo pero creo yo que
claramente hay dos factores que a mí me
parece se soslayan tanto en mi coalición
como también en el espectro político en
general Yo creo que el escenario
político cambió con la pandemia Y eso
invertible los ánimos el estado anímico
de la población su estado de salud sus
condiciones cambiaron completamente el
escenario pre pandemia en el cual
iniciamos este proceso constitucional y
las discusiones en nuestro país era muy
distinto del post pandemia y creo yo
también que el escenario pospandemia y
el salir nuevamente después de mucho
rato estar en nuestras casas estar en
una situación de aislamiento sino a
generar toda esta situación de
contingencia que hoy día enfrentamos
como país que es con cifras de
delincuencia y de inseguridad que hace
mucho tiempo no veíamos
usted usted cree y considera que existe
el riesgo que los republicanos que hacen
parte de este consejo vayan mucho más
allá y se salgan de los doce principios
que se pactaron en el acuerdo por chile
un poco antes de eso yo yo quiero a lo
mejor Daniel porque es muy joven No de
haber leído todos los libros que se han
escrito respecto de como la izquierda
chilena y latinoamericana anti respetado
al principio de propiedad eso no es un
mito eso está en los libros y y lo
siguiente un poco yendo a la a la
pregunta suya bueno esto Esto es otro
proceso lo que la gente votó el año o lo
que quiso acordarse el 2019 y lo que se
votó o el borrador constitucional que
salió el dos y lo que se rechazó son
procesos distintos y son momentos
distintos Aquí no hay una una rueda
clavada de la fortuna no hay algo que
haya que mantener Simplemente porque la
mayoría van cambiando la y lo sabe
perfectamente Daniel él tiene un
presidente hoy día que fue electo con la
primera mayoría relativa y hoy día su su
coalición está siendo fuertemente
rechazada en Chile entonces lo que hay
hoy día es otro proceso y es un proceso
donde las personas por lo menos que yo
hago yo no pertenezco al al partido
republicano y no pertenezco a ninguna de
las coaliciones políticas que están hoy
día acá pero quiero decir que hoy día la
la ciudadanía lo que ha intentado hacer
es Ojalá darle un mandato a las personas
que que piensan que son más capaces para
que conduzcan nuevamente este proceso
por una vía de de paz entonces yo siento
que la situación hay que nos llevó la la
izquierda o el extrema izquierda con
cuestiones que sí están fuera de la
tradición constitucional chilena esto no
debe volver a suceder lo que lo que
chile tiene que asegurar es la vida la
libertad y la propiedad que son los
principios básicos de cualquier
Constitución el respeto a los derechos
individuales por supuesto la no
injerencia del Estado Ojalá mínima o
inexistente en la vida de las personas y
y seguir conduciendo un proceso por un
camino que además a nosotros nos ha
llevado a ser líderes en gran parte de
los índices en América Latina Aunque
el frente amplio y los partidos de
extrema izquierda no lo no lo conozcan o
lo desconozcan esto efectivamente este
marco constitucional que uno le puede
encontrar defectos y puede tener
problemas como cualquier otra
Constitución es la que ha llevado a que
chile se haya desarrollado como lo hizo
en los últimos en los años 90 ya para ir
cerrando nuestro programa y acercándonos
al final que lastimosamente se nos acaba
el tiempo yo quiero puntualizar algo que
usted menciona pasábamos de una
convención Constituyente conformada
principalmente por candidatos
independientes a un consejo
constitucional conformado por derecha y
extrema derecha al final Entonces cuál
puede ser el resultado Daniel puede caer
chile en el riesgo de primero tener una
constitución más adaptada y más según el
molde de pensamientos progresistas y
ahora caer más en que sea un molde de la
derecha y la extrema derecha y al final
quedarse sin el pan y sin el queso como
decimos coloquialmente y quedarse sin la
posibilidad de una nueva constitución
bueno claramente
estamos en una situación preocupante
aquí quien tiene el santés por el mango
como lo decimos coloquialmente también
él es el partido republicano y es chile
seguro si ellos tienen la posibilidad de
generar grandes acuerdos porque entre
esas dos almas también hay profundas y
radicales diferencias tienen la
posibilidad de generar acuerdos
transversales y en base a esos acuerdos
transversales también poder sentarse a a
a a a a discutir el nuevo chile y la
nueva propuesta constitucional con los
consejeros electos de unidad para Chile
que aglutina los partidos de gobierno
Creo yo que podemos tener un buen
resultado pero si a la vuelta de la
esquina están como vuelvo a a citar
algunos parlamentarios republicanos que
están indicando que van a desconocer las
bases fundamentales de este proceso
constitucional que no van a ser mejora
en la línea de las ideas transversales
que se han generado como acuerdo derecha
izquierda hoy día ha tenido precisamente
grandes acuerdos en algunas ideas que
son fundamentales para resolver
matemáticas que hoy día nos aquejan como
país Yo creo que podríamos asegurar un
buen resultado pero si no se genera esa
voluntad si no hay diálogo si no hay
capacidad de poder dialogar con los que
piensan distinto y el partido
republicano quiere sentar sus ideas en
este proceso constitucional yo no tengo
ninguna duda de que este proceso
constitucional va a generar serios
antagonismo el resultado no va a ser
fructífero y Considero que sería
lamentable para el futuro de nuestro
país yo espero de verdad y de muy buena
fe que esto no suceda y que el partido
republicano pueda liderar aunque eso
vaya a generarle eventuales buenas
oportunidades para el día de mañana
ellos hacerse precisamente del del del
gobierno en el futuro en el en el buen
sentido del del destino nuestro país que
así sea pero yo la verdad lo interrumpo
Daniel para lo interrumpo a Daniel para
darle paso a Felipe Felipe muy
brevemente habrá Constitución a la
medida de la derecha de chile O podrá
haber un diálogo para una carta magna
incluyente
Yo confío en que este nuevo proceso
tome lo mejor de la tradición
constitucional chilena que dé cuenta de
los problemas que institucionales o
constitucionales eventualmente
eventuales pudo haber tenido esta nueva
constitución
yo por lo menos Creo que ninguna persona
va a llegar vestida de de Pikachu a este
dinosaurio a esta convención
constitucional
también me gusta mucho lo que dice
Daniel porque Daniel representa una una
coalición que ha tenido prácticas
totalitarias si uno lo uno ve como ellos
trabajan o trabajaron durante la
comisión constitucional donde imponían
sus mayorías simplemente ni siquiera
tomando en cuenta lo que las minorías
querían querían indicar Bueno me parece
muy bien que haya habido un giro en por
lo menos algunos personeros del frente
amplio de buscar hoy día acuerdos de
Buscar que exista diálogo yo creo que
las personas que han sido electas muchos
de ellos son personas públicas son
personas reconocidas
hay una hay una una convicción de de
expertos que probablemente también va a
conducir respecto de lo que se puede y
no se puede hacer así que yo creo que
eventualmente este nuevo proceso
constitucional debiera ser
sustancialmente mejor que el que el
proceso que lideró la extrema izquierda
chilena Felipe en un minuto muy
brevemente Cuál es su conclusión de cómo
entender las elecciones del Consejo
constitucional
como un rechazo al gobierno un rechazo
al frente amplio un rechazo a los
valores del frente amplio un rechazo a
la violencia política un rechazo de las
promesas sin fundamento un rechazo a la
demagogia un rechazo al populismo y
obviamente hay esperanza de que este
nueva personas que están en el proceso
Constituyente puedan conducir
adecuadamente este proceso hasta el mes
de diciembre y que de una vez por todas
que le salga de esta tuyadero en que lo
envió la clase política Daniel muy
brevemente también un minuto la
conclusión de Cómo entender los últimos
comicios de Chile
bueno los últimos comicios nos invitan a
que tenemos que hacernos cargo de
construir un proyecto político de
izquierda que permita entregarle una
alternativa al país que permita
entregarle propuestas concretas que
permita también entregarle Cuál es
nuestra visión y nuestra propuesta de
nueva constitución para el país que
permita también generar la alerta y los
llamados atención para que el gobierno
tenga que tomar todas las medidas y
generar toda la autocrítica que permitan
que pueda recuperar el control de la
agenda en el país y muy muy muy muy muy
muy importante Aún es un llamado de
atención para que precisamente nos
hagamos cargo de una crisis política que
es transversal a toda la clase política
la deslegitimidad de las instituciones
la es legitimidad del proceso del
proceso constitucional en sí no
olvidarnos de que hubo prácticamente un
20% de votos nulos y que por lo tanto no
hubo ninguna candidatura ninguna lista
ni ninguna coalición que convocó a
nuestra ciudadanía Así que son múltiples
tareas pero me quedo con la que señalaba
el primer punto donde tenemos que
abocarnos completamente a la generación
de un proyecto político transversal
colectivo amplio y que precisamente le
entregue una espalda mucho más grande a
lo que hoy día es nuestro gobierno que
precisamente todavía le queda más de la
mitad del mandato y tiene que trabajar
fuertemente por resolver los problemas
más urgentes que existen en Chile que
están dado y ahí tengo una diferencia
con lo que planteaba Felipe pero es
indiscutible que hemos crecido y que
avanzamos como país los últimos 50 años
sobre todo en un contexto donde se nos
impuso una constitución pero también
se nos acaba el tiempo simplemente para
recordar que la decisión final estará en
manos de los chilenos en el plebiscito
que votará en el próximo 17 de diciembre
para decidir si aprueban o rechazan el
segundo borrador Daniel Olivares Y
Felipe munizaga Gracias por acompañarnos
gracias a ustedes Muchas gracias por su
sintonía la producción del debate estuvo
a cargo de Andrés doncelli la producción
de invitados con Tania Herrera en nombre
de todos nosotros y también de nuestro
equipo técnico los invitamos a que sigan
con nosotros aquí en France 24
[Música]